we are taking phone calls sort of
they're really kind of like
voip calls i guess through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to
i believe it's nikki from germany
nikki from germany is that right
nikki from germany you're on the air
nicki from germany last chance
and nikki from germany is gone let's go
to bryce
from illinois bryce you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
fantastic how are you doing today i'm
doing well
good so i've just got uh i guess a
couple quick questions kind of joking
mildly just to
i don't know get the break the ice a
little bit and then i guess more of a
serious question if that's all right
that works with you
okay so first question
boxers or briefs oh i i
i have a video on youtube about this so
i refuse to answer it in perpetuity
you just have to go and look at the
boxers or briefs video on youtube
oh i i see fair enough fair enough
um i guess my other question is you live
in new york city right
near new york city yeah i don't say
exactly where okay
fair enough but i guess what's your
transport situation
like between i guess your home and
office i have not been
on uh i have not been on public
transport since
february of 2020.
i just what do you do in order to get
around you have a car i have a car
i have a car i've been getting really
into
small unique electric vehicles lately
they have electric unicycles whole
host of interesting things so just a
matter of curiosity more than anything
but yeah no these are serious questions
so i i guess
i'll propose a more serious question um
have you seen
the film idiocracy uh by mike judge
yes i have
what do you think the odds are with you
know the
50 of the republican party that refuses
to acknowledge that joe biden won the
election do you think that
that 50 could potentially weigh us down
enough to where that is
a reasonably uh valid situation that
could
happen if we don't blow ourselves up
beforehand
yeah i don't know specifically what
which part you mean but yes
i've expressed significant concern about
the fact that you know
disagreements about what the tax rate
should be
or how big a um
you know how abhorrent
uh complete lack of trust in in science
yes yes that's extremely concerning that
is extremely concerning
i don't know how we fix it and and we've
talked about it quite a bit
um all right thank you my friend
appreciate the call i'm going to move on
a bit let's talk to uh andrew from miami
andrew you are on the air hi david can
you hear me yes i can
i'm wondering what your thoughts are on
biden running on
things like canceling student debt or
providing a public option
and then when he actually gains power he
doesn't really seem to have the means or
desire to enact any of those policies
yeah i mean listen i would take issue i
don't know that biden ran on canceling
student debt i think that towards the
end of the
campaign pressure made him say he'd
consider canceling some amount of it but
not
fifty thousand dollars i think he was
talking about ten needless to say
as i've said before i don't think he
really has any interest in doing it and
um on that it it's just he's just not
interested in it and i disagree with him
on the policy
but joe biden never seemed to me
interested
in actually doing that now on the public
option
um healthcare is you know he did covet
stimulus
and that tweaked obamacare to some
degree
and now he's got infrastructure the jobs
plan tax reform
i am still open to the idea that joe
biden will make a good faith effort to
put a public option
in place he may not do it he may not do
it
because he doesn't try hard enough or he
may not do it because he's not able to
get it done i'm reserving judgment
until we see because we're only four
months into his presidency
what does it mean to you to not try hard
enough to get something as significant
as public health options
well listen i mean joe you you sort of
know it when you see it uh joe biden
touts how he's been a deal maker who can
negotiate with democrats and republicans
for his entire career
so if joe biden simply says
i'd like a public option that would be a
great thing and
you know three democrats say we don't
want it and then you never hear about it
again i think most of us would sort of
agree that's not really trying giving
that's not really giving a good faith
effort
if he puts together a proposal with
democrats that want it
and it includes a public option and when
whoever joe manchin or whatever comes
out and says i don't want that
he brings them to the white house and he
meets any lobbies any pushes
i think we will all know whether it was
a good faith effort or not
well i mean that sort of reminds me of
the discussion that came around the 15
minimum wage you know he's supposed to
be this
great i mean we don't want to say deal
maker because that reminds us of the
previous administration
yeah but if you're supposed to bring
together democrats and republicans to
to enact things that are overwhelmingly
popular with the public
the 15 minimum wage sort of fell through
and he sort of let that happen
by saying something along the lines of
uh you know
we don't think it'll pass given the
current you know
yeah he didn't even i mean listen he
didn't even have every democratic
senator on board it was there was just
no way and as i've spoken about before
we can argue that morally the
parliamentarian should have included it
and
let them all vote no and in practice
it would have just delayed people
getting a covet cash that's
in practice what it would have done we
would have a naughty and nice list
but we sort of do anyway we sort of know
who is against it
so i i agree with you i don't think
there was any way
anything would happen other than just
delaying people get forgetting fourteen
hundred dollars and i'm for the fifteen
dollar minimum wage to be clear
great that's great to hear um it just
seems so interesting how when
things come up in terms of propagating
the war machine
or other things involving funding the
private sector
it always seems like that money is
available when it but when it comes to
funding a 15
minimum wage of course and those things
are more difficult to happen
100 that's we never question where will
we get the money for all these bombs and
missiles and rockets
100 right and that's an analysis i've
been making for some time and you're
you you couldn't be more right excellent
glad you agree thanks so much david all
right gonna let you go the audio really
uh sort of kind of falling apart there
towards the end but it sort of held
to some degree for a period of time one
of our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my vincero
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman